so one big thing is accountability
mirror
you have to start with yourself
so what happened in my life
was we start to get i call it like the
rucksack a rucksack is a pack that you
carry in the military
and you put all your stuff in it your
radios your food your water all that
stuff you have to carry the military
that's your rucksack it's a backpack
pretty much
as you're growing up
we all have a backpack most of ours
hopefully is empty you know and what we
put in it is all the crap we go through
in life
that's what is in the backpack for the
civilians and we carry it around with us
so what you have to start doing is
realizing that no matter where you're at
in life
i got called [ __ ] a lot my dad abused
me
you know learning disability stutters
immaturity insecurities self-doubt so
much crap on top of me
so much stuff i lied a lot to create
friends so people so much stuff was in
my backpack
no one's coming back to help me
so it starts with that person in that
mirror
you have to realize you are on your own
now and whatever else you believe in i
don't care what you believe in but
on earth it's a very lonely journey
it starts with the accountability mirror
of looking at saying hey my dad who beat
the hell he's not coming back all these
things are coming back i have to face
myself
and you have to own
all those things that people may have
done to you now it's yours you got to
own it it's yours now to fix the
problems that people did to you it makes
no sense it's not fair
i get it but if you live in that what
was me mentality of guess what
my dad did this to me my mom just did to
me people who bullied did this to me
you're going to always live right there
you have to figure out ways to move
forward because you're not coming back
it starts with the mirror i call it the
accountability mirror in the book it's
not fair you're right it is not fair the
situation that you're in the people
around you the lack of resources that
you have it is not fair i agree with you
so now what because you have a very
important choice to make the past does
not have to equal the future where you
start it from does not have to be where
you end up all of your heroes overcame
bigger obstacles and what's in front of
you right now so now what are you going
to take accountability and create a new
life or keep complaining about how your
current life is not fair let me tell you
a quick story about friend of the
channel alex saiyan who helps me run
toronto dance salsa alex was a student
at tds for a number of years and badly
wanted to be a helper helpers are
advanced students who then helped
volunteer their time to help out the
other students
he was rejected
he was rejected over and over and over
again that he was not good enough to be
a helper finally he got accepted to be a
helper his next step was he wanted to be
assistant then he wanted to be an
instructor and over and over and over
again while people are getting promoted
and given opportunities alex just didn't
have the material alex kept getting said
no no no no no you're not ready you have
to fix this you got to fix that you're
not good enough yet keep going home keep
working on it
eventually he got to the point
where sharon who is the original owner
of the studio
said okay alex i'm going to train you to
be an instructor
years after where most people would have
been given the opportunity alex finally
earned his way in it's easy for him to
have said hey it's not fair why are
other people getting opportunities ahead
of me hey it's not fair on me but he
kept going he kept working he'd get
grinding then disaster struck
finally he got that opportunity right to
be trained to be an instructor and then
sharon the lead instructor
heard her back and couldn't train with
him
so she asked me to come in and help
teach the class there's a problem though
you can't have two guys at the front of
a class i couldn't dance with alex
that's not traditionally how classes are
run
so alex was defeated finally he had
worked so hard to get this opportunity
and then he realized i'm gonna have to
go back to just being on the sidelines
because emma's gonna come in and teach
the class now i didn't think alex was
ready
i
had known him for a number of years i
didn't think he was responsible enough i
didn't think he had what it took but
because sharon had made a deal with him
i decided i would honor that deal
and on the day that he came to pick me
up to go to the studio
i said alex we got two options
the class is happening tonight
either i could run the class
and do it and you can sit on the
sidelines and watch
or
you can run the class and i'll sit on
the sidelines and i will guide and
mentor you
you get the pick but you have to decide
right now because we're driving the
class and we're going to be there in 15
minutes what do you want to do
and to my
not just surprise but also
admiration he said i want to do it
he wasn't quite ready to take on the
whole class but he said i'm going to do
it and he went up but he did it was it
amazing no but it was momentum and he
kept going and now
fast forward to today
if you gave me a brand new salsa student
and said
this person has to learn salsa and i
wanted to have a fun time doing it
i would put money on alex over anybody
in the world to give them the best
possible experience i would from a guy
who i didn't believe would be a good
instructor to now being the best in the
world
how well he had to overcome
all these things that weren't fair
he had to overcome growing up having
super sweaty hands and not being able to
touch a girl so he never learned to
dance until he became an adult he had to
overcome years of people passing him by
getting opportunities ahead of him
because he wasn't good enough he had to
overcome waiting to get his chance to be
trained to be an instructor and then
finally here it is it all happens and it
looks like the whole thing is going to
get ripped away from him
because the woman who was training him
couldn't teach anymore
and then he had one shot and that's all
it takes
you will get your one shot you will get
your one shot if you keep going you will
get your one shot if you take
accountability you will get your one
shot what do you do when you get your
one shot but you feel like you're not
ready yet
because that's the pivotal moment where
you can decide i'm going to fall back to
the life that i had or i'm going to step
forward into a brave new world that i
don't know how it exists yet
and i'm scared and i'm not ready but i'm
gonna take it
but if alex told himself it's not fair
that all these things have happened to
me he would never got his one shot it
wouldn't happen
and so i'm gonna give you three ways
that you can make alex's story your
story that you can make every success
story every person you look up to their
success story can be your story using
this three-step process here we go set
number one get clear on what you want
what do you want
make it super clear you can't just want
a better life what does that look like
get super clear on what it is that you
are going after write it down one
sentence make it clear for yourself make
it clear for the people around you make
it clear for anybody who comes in
contact with you say hey what do you
want this this is what i want i have
absolute focus and when people look at
you and say
you're never going to do that look at
where you're coming from that's okay
because you have direction right the
world gets out of the way for the person
who knows what they want you need to get
clear on what you want get it down to
one sentence step number two is study
three people who've done it before study
three people who have done exactly the
thing that you want to do look at them
look at how they started right not how
they're winning now amazing started how
did they get started what were the
obstacles they had to overcome because
chances are they had to overcome a lot
of obstacles and in looking at their
stories it gives you two things it gives
you one motivation to see where they
came from to where they are now that's
motivation and two it gives you tactics
gives you strategies gives you ideas
you get to learn how they overcame those
obstacles that feeling of it's not fair
that feeling if i don't have the
resources to help me go and then boom
they go off and blow up
if alex looked at sharon who started the
school sharon started it as an adult she
didn't have dancing growing up she
started as an adult she was the worst
dancer of her friends when she started
to learn she was the worst one of the
first guys to dance with her left her in
the middle of a song on the dance floor
for a lot of people that be soul
crushing that would be
it's not fair it's not fair i didn't go
to school for this i didn't learn this
growing up i'm trying to learn this as
an adult i don't i don't have what it
takes it's not fair
it's not fair for that guy to be so mean
it's not fair great she said you know
what
yeah it's not fair but i'm gonna keep
going so study three people who've done
exactly the thing that you want to do
learn from them get motivated by them
and use their strategies to work for you
and step number three is create ceo time
you need to create ceo time ceo time
means you're working on being the ceo of
your business and your life
the ceo that big goal that you set in
step number one
that demands a ceo if you want that goal
to happen you need to step up and be the
ceo of architecting that goal into
existence
and so you need to have ceo time
somewhere in your calendar
you need to pull out your calendar
however you're using it if it's google
calendars or notebook or whatever you're
using
and every week there needs to be a chunk
of time
a window
of ceo time and in that time you're
going to be spending your absolute focus
on driving that number one goal into
fruition
creating it into existence
so when is that gonna happen for you
pull out your calendar and make it
happen if you're only spending half an
hour a week on ceo time
well your goal is going to come to you
very slowly
most of the world wakes up and has zero
ceo time you're just in reaction
complaining mode so half an hour is
better than nothing but can you spend
two hours three hours four hours
more
ceo time not reacting to people not
getting distracted not working on
projects that other people want you to
work on every week put into your
calendar right now block it off put
gates around it so people don't trample
all over your time you got to protect it
because if you're not spending time on
ceo time every week you're not building
the life that you want now i've got a
really special bonus clip that i think
you're going to enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action for the next week
the sign says that when you just watch a
video you get motivated to get inspired
you have a 35 chance of following
through on your goals 35 that's not
enough that's not enough just to get
motivated believe nation we're here
you're here today matters you're an
action taker
when you commit to a plan of action
of when and how you're going to follow
through when you write it down you have
a 91 chance of following through and
when you commit publicly to somebody
else that jumps to 95 chance from 30
something percent to 95 chance of you
falling through believe nation we need
to make this happen so question of the
day your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action
specific for the next week put it down
in the comments below and i'm going to
show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you
where do i want to be in life where do i
see myself
and then i start making these plans and
how i'm going to get there and i don't
deviate from that plan
so that's kind of how i do them now i
mean it's a lot more to it than that
but it's a lot of quiet time
i shut out a lot of noise i only have
people in my life that that need to be
there
if you don't need to be in my life i'm
not about acquiring more friends
i'm not about noise i'm about okay are
you trying to go somewhere you can you
can jump on board if not i don't want to
hear all your problems
you have a solution for your problem
that's what i'm all about right now so
i'm not about whining bitching
complaining i'm about okay we need to go
this way i came home one night from work
spraying for cockroaches
and
um long story short i turned on the
discovery channel i saw some guys going
through navy seal training
and they were going through hell week
and they're getting their ass just beat
you know in and out of the water guys
ringing the bell
um there's suffering and i was weighing
like 297 pounds
and i had to make a change in my life
you know i was at an all-time low
and i wasn't going anywhere and i was
exactly what everybody said i was going
to be which was nothing
so i had to make a change what was it
about seeing suffering that's that's
really interesting and i actually get it
but i want to hear you explain it why
suffering was the thing that triggered
that thought
well for me growing up i came from a
horrible background i got called [ __ ]
every day of my life growing up um
living a small town
the klan headquarters at that time
was about
um
20 minutes from where i lived
the uh
one of the high ups in the kkk son sat
behind me in two classes so he called me
[ __ ] all the time i got my first car
they spray printed [ __ ] we're gonna
kill you on it so
i was just an insecure scared kid
and the only way i could find myself
was through putting myself through the
worst thing possible because i'm going
to say the exact opposite of what the
world today's world is saying so we read
a bunch of books nowadays as humans we
we want to find out how to be someone
else
what we don't do is we don't go
inside so literally turn yourself inside
out read the book that says like we're
writing a book every day of our lives
every day
we're seeing who we are as people when i
was growing up i i lied for people to
accept me because i didn't accept myself
so i would make up stories so then you
would accept me into your world
i would uh everything i did was for
someone else to like me it wasn't until
i started reading my own book about how
pathetic i was as a human being i could
blame my dad i can blame kids at school
i could blame having health issues atd
my mom not being around great mom but
she was doing her thing right i could
blame a lot of people
and that's the book i was reading
and i put it off on everybody else it
went until i said you know what for me
to fix this i get to read what what the
[ __ ] is wrong with david goggins not
blame anybody
read my book it's okay i'm afraid of my
shadow
how can i overcome that
go in the military get your ass kicked
do things you hate to do be
uncomfortable every day of your life
roger that i'm not the smartest kid in
the world
okay is that somebody saying oh no
you're smart no no don't say that to
yourself i said to myself no i'm a
okay roger that how you get smarter
educate yourself
so the things that we run from we run
them from the truth
we're running from the truth man so the
only way i became successful
was going towards the truth as painful
and as brutal
as it is
it changed me
it allowed me to become
in my own right
who i am today david
tell them about the cookie jar
the cookie jar it's something i invented
as you all know your mom has a cookie
jar and sometimes you might have oreo
sometimes you might have a chips ahoy
sometimes you might have a oatmeal
raisin cookie you never know it's just
in there
my cookie jar
has
every single failure and success of my
life except i overcame
so what happens in this in time of life
when you're stressed out and things get
bad even the hardest guy in the world
me everybody thinks and i think i'm the
hardest guy in the world you gotta
believe that you gotta believe you are
something i will in my mind
reach into my cookie jar
and sometimes you forget how hard you
are in times of of need
you because you're you're stressed
but you forget i'm a navy seal i'm a
ranger i'm this and that but you forget
all that cause your life sucks
i calm down take that one second get
control of my life
reaching the cookie jar
well you gotta call [ __ ] your whole
life and you're now the only person in
history do this this and this
put it back in the cookie jar reset my
mind you have to remind yourself of how
badass you really are
in times of need
that's the cookie jar so many of us are
on cruise control myself included and we
get into our daily routine and routines
are unbelievable but routines can also
be a rut only if you really challenge
yourself and push yourself and get out
of your routine your comfort zone can
you get better like you can't improve
when you're on autopilot so you have to
set goals and you have to set um
challenges that you don't necessarily
think you can do or are going to push
yourself way further than you think you
can
to improve so you got to get out of the
complacency of the routine the whole
thing about comfort zones is if you live
in one for too long that becomes your
norm it never allows you to
get experience gain knowledge gain any
kind of
mental toughness well i learned that we
all have a reserve tank that we're all
capable of doing so much more than we
think we can
and um only by really tapping into that
reserve tank whether it's in business
whether it's in physically you want to
get more fit
only when you really push yourself and
push your limits can you find out what
you're really made of and what's in your
reserve tank and i mean he taught me
that every single day
and it just led to me getting better in
the various parts of my life as i tapped
into that reserve tank yeah i think i
said don't be
you know we call it the 40 rule that's
something that david uh kind of
told me and shared with me and i bought
into it and it's but it's proved
effective not just in working out but
even in business or my family life it's
like when i'm frustrated when i'm done
when i hit a roadblock when things get
complicated you have so much more in you
people are saying man you cuss all the
time why
well
i hate to say it the best way for me to
get how i feel across
i can't sit here and say you know what
yeah i went through hell weekend man it
was it was really hard
no that
takes your damn soul rips it inside out
and then they say
now we're going to
start
it it allows me to express
where i was at at a point of my life
if i don't give you all of me
why how will you learn from me
people take so much offense to me
you will never learn from people if we
always tap dance around the truth oh god
i love that we tap dance around the
truth by
finding the right word so i don't hurt
you because you have thin skin
no
tighten up people it's okay trust me
it's okay you might be called [ __ ] one
day
it's okay
you might be called some jewish word or
some [ __ ] or gay word it's okay
let them call you that what are you
going to do now they don't own your life
how are you going to control that now
how are you going to flip it upside down
and say roger that
now i'm going to harness this
and you'll read about me years from now
how that's the question how are you
going to do that
thicken your skin
become more of a human being don't be
afraid of the reflection in the mirror
because that's all you can be afraid of
once you overcome the reflection in the
mirror
you've done it
i literally broke
all the metatarsals in my feet
stretch fractures shin splints
everything the pain going with my body
i've been through every training on the
man range of school hell week three
times all kind of stuff this event i'm
explaining to you right now enough time
to explain to you in detail was the
worst thing i've done in my entire life
pain wise this is when i realized human
being is capable of going through limits
unknown to most people
this is where hardness comes in people
can read a book on hardness and tell you
about mental toughness and hardness but
until you put your body through hardness
and realize that there's walls and doors
you must break through and once you
break through them you are amazing
and your body resets
but we are scared to get to that wall
because that wall says what stop right
but every wall has a what
a door
you got to get that key from your pocket
and don't be scared to see someone else
at the door i would like to know when
you're in that moment failing
and you have to keep going what do you
say to yourself
what if
a lot of times i'll be in a 200-mile run
or something like that
and i'm all jacked up
body's broken mine's broken spirit's
broken
i start to say what i can pull this off
when i first walked into the navy seal
recruiter's office he looked at me and
said there's only been 35 african
americans in 70 years make it through
you know i said to myself
what if i can be the 36th
it's the what if
i can pull off a miracle
what if i can become someone that no one
thinks i can be and just that just me
talking about that
i have the hair going up on my arms
because it makes me just like
what if
i can be that guy that people who call
[ __ ] and this and that and now
i'm speaking at tom ferry's event the
first ultra marathon wasn't smart at all
at all
um
just so basically what happened was i
was at military free fall school with
morgan latrell
marcus cettrell if you guys don't know
was the lone survivor of the guy
he um was in a bad op off went bad he
was the only navy so that lived
long story short you got to get the book
read loan survivor great story morgan is
marcus charles twin brother
and i was there with marcus so what
happened was myself and morgan were in
free fall school at the same exact time
marcus
was in the worst incident in still
history so i knew that marcus might be
dead he wasn't dead everybody else was
dead so i actually brought
more you know i actually told morgan hey
man your brother wasn't a bad incident i
don't know if he's alive i don't know
what's going on long story short marcus
is alive
and i go on to want to raise money for
families all these guys died they all
had kids i want to raise money for the
special operations warrior foundation
it's a foundation where 100 tuition goes
to
these kids to go to college you know
full tuition whatever
so i found this great foundation i'm
going to raise money for it so i said
you know what i have to google something
that's that's evil something very hard i
knew nothing about ultra marathons i
hadn't even run a marathon i knew
nothing about this world
so i googled that you know the top 10
hardest races in the world and what
comes up is a bad water 135. so her 35
mile race through death valley in the
summer time
i thought it was a stage race
i thought it was a race where you run
like 20 miles set up camp you know
barbecue outside and then go run some
more the next day
so i called the race director up at the
race and said hey chris his name is
chris kaufman i want to do your race so
we had a long conversation you know i
was i was much heavier than
and i hadn't put running shoes on over a
year how heavy are you at this point i'm
around between 240 to 270. whoa i'm in
there i'm in that range i've my weight
has buried a lot through the seal teams
and out of this hill team so i was a
heavy guy but the long and short of it
all was i hadn't put running shoes on in
over a year i was a big time power
lifter i lift their weights heavy that's
what i did right i just got back home
from iraq went straight to freefall
school
and then this happened so i called chris
kosman up on a wednesday he says look
man the only way you can qualify for my
race is to run 100 miles at one time
in 24 hours or less
there happened to be a race
that saturday so four days later
and he said if you qualify by running a
hundred miles or less in 24 hours i will
consider you my race
i'm gonna cut to the chase
i signed up for this race it's called a
san diego one day where you run around a
one-mile track for 24 hours to see many
miles you can get my goal was 100 miles
so
um i got to mile 70
and i cleared 70 miles in like 12 13
hours pretty quickly but i was done my
feet were broken i was stress fractured
shin splints
muscles were tearing i was in bad shape
i was eating rich crackers and drinking
bioclips
that's all i had
no water didn't know what i was doing
out there had on some tube socks it was
just ridiculous it was it was a clown
show
so
i sat down at mile 70 and at this time i
was married
and i i looked at my wife and i was like
um
i'm i'm messed up bad
so i literally start to turn white and
when a black guy turns white you're
pretty
so
here i am i'm all [ __ ] up in this
chair
i'm at mile 70. if i got 30 miles to go
i'm jacked up i got to go to the
bathroom and the bathroom's like 20 feet
from me it's a porta potty i can't get
out of the chair so i'm peeing blood
down my leg whoa
pooping up my back
and i got 30 miles to go
and i'm i can't stand up because my my
blood pressure's all messed up i've been
in three hell weeks ranger school
overcome so many obstacles in my life
this last 30 miles of this race
is when i realized
a human being
is not so human anymore
we have the ability to go
in such a space
if you're willing to suffer
and i mean suffer your brain and your
body once connected together can do
anything
and this 30 miles was the life-changing
moment
i was out of it i was in the worst pain
in my entire life
i was to me
on the brink of death
and i was able to chunk this 30 damn
miles
into small pieces i was so driven
and i'm not going to say motivated
because motivation is crap motivation
comes and goes
when you're driven whatever's in front
of you will get destroyed
so i sat in this chair and i was so
driven
to succeed in this race and at this time
everybody goes were you thinking about
the guys that died and
i'm not gonna lie to you i wasn't
this became a personal
thing
this became me against this race me
against the kids that called me [ __ ]
me against me
it it just became something that i took
so
so violently personal
and i broke this thing down into small
pieces i said okay i got to get
nutrition i gotta be able to stand up
before i can get off this curb and get
off this chair and be able to go 30
miles
so i went through all these small steps
and i was able to stand up
and then from staying up
i was literally walking around with my
wife at the time and she goes you're not
gonna make the time she goes you're
running i mean you're walking like 30 or
some minute miles
i got to my 81
and the second she said that i'm not
gonna make the time
i ran the last 19 miles non-stop
and i can show you right now when we get
done with this matter of fact i'm going
to show you right now
this was years ago
and i had to put compression tape
on my ankle and i had so this was years
ago
i had
literally the size of half dollars
i had to get compression tape
and i taped up my ankles and i taped up
my feet and that's how i got through
that race it was like a hematoma i mean
what do we know see what happened was
like my shins
hurt so bad from having stretch
fractures that the only way i could
continue on was i taped it so i wasn't
doing the flexor motion that that
activates
your your shins
so i taped my ankles and my shins up and
i got that from
because in my third hell week
they won't let me go back through you
know train anymore right
so i literally went through
all the buds my last seal training with
stretch fractures and shin splints and
how i did it was i would take my ankles
all the way up to my calf every morning
so for the first hour the pain was
excruciating but what happened is my
feet would go numb
and i did that every single day for six
months
whoa and that's how i got through my
third healthy because i was so broken
from the first two
that the commander said hey the ceo said
this your last time we're sending you
through so that's how i got the idea
to do that so
with the right and people may listen to
this and say
this guy is sadistic he's crazy he's
no if you know how i came up
you realize i was just
a scared kid
that found drive and passion to be
something much better than what he
thought he was that's all it is
self-talk
and visualization are the two keys to my
success
i believed
for that last time 19 miles i was
indestructible
because i took myself in that chair
crapping up my back peeing blood in my
leg shin splint stretch fractures
i use all that for motivation versus
negativity i use it for motivation i i
said to myself who on this
earth
would still be going right now
you are
you are
you got to be the hardest mother
planet is it true i don't give a [ __ ]
at that time right
it got me to the finish line of that
race
i believed it i believe it today i
believed it enough to where my body said
he's not going to stop
and that's
i took all the negative things
i need to go to the hospital this and
that and i use all
could even get out of that chair you did
who the hell would you think about
taping stress fractures up
you did
all those things i used for motivation
[Music]
i started doing this triathlons and
enduring sports ultra runs just to test
my soul to see what i'm about to see
in 150 mile race at mile 75 when i feel
really bad
that's when you know that's the only
time you can find out what the human
body is all about what what you're made
of to find out
limits
to myself
limits to the human soul
and every day i'm trying to see if i
have limits
i run anywhere from 125 150 in a week so
i'll try and put in about 450 miles a
month
usually every day i wake up at 3 o'clock
in the morning and i run anywhere from
10 to 15 miles in the morning and then i
i live about 25 miles from work
so i get my bicycle commute into work
do a normal work day at lunchtime around
noon
i'll run again anywhere from five to
eight miles whatever maybe come back
work
and around 5 30 i'll ride back home 25
miles on my bike
if i'm feeling good and when i get more
miles i'll get off the bike and do like
a short three or four or five mile run
that's my everyday life so i don't just
train like an hour or so
i train until something is uncomfortable
and then naturally you know who you are
[Music]
the only easy day was yesterday
it just never ends i mean i've done some
races where you're on a one-mile track
and you're running for 48 hours straight
so imagine running 48 hours and running
one mile track
and it's not like you're sleeping you're
you're running for 48 hours how many
miles you can get
i want to talk about mine torture
[Music]
my life doesn't have a finish line
so when i cross the finish line of the
iron man it doesn't matter because i
know that you know two or three weeks
from now i'll be doing something else to
put my body through more pain
i believe you know everything i try to
do is kind of defined by excellence
but
i don't think i ever reach excellence
myself because i have my standards of my
life are really high
so i don't ever reach it but i try to
every day
you have to be a good individual first
before you can be a good team player
i know for a fact how bad hell we get i
i went through it a couple times it's
probably the most brutal like brutal
military training anybody can go through
so everybody's my left and everybody to
my right they've been through this so i
know mentally
you know these individuals are extremely
hard
and when stuff gets bad and you know in
any situation i know these guys have my
back
[Music]
i've done a lot of things i thought were
impossible and nothing's impossible
anymore i say what if a lot it sounds
corny and it sounds weak but it's true
one of the recruiters said there's not
many black navy salesmen in fact i was a
36 african american seal in history
it's in over 70 years
because the water you know i mean people
get mad at me it's true just get over it
and
so
i was like man
what story would it be if
fat dumb
lying to be friends with people insecure
act
can overcome the
and that what if mentality like
that that dreamer mentality just would
always fuel me
it was true man what if i can be
what if i can be a seal man
what if i can go from where in a quarter
of a mile now and i'll run 205 miles
what if i can go but just what if i can
go in
and what if how would that feel if i'm
graduating kind of get at the graduation
thing i was talking about 2 24 that like
the video i sat down and watched
this command officer stood up and he
said to the graduation um guys who are
graduating buds like 18 of them
he said we live in a society where
mediocrity is often rewarded
and he went on to say something about
these men detest mediocrity
and
i wanted to be a man that detests
mediocrity what power have you found in
the darkness
first of all before i answer that
question i want to say everybody listen
to this um
i'm
the happiest man on the planet earth
so people may take this and as so many
people do we live in a very weakened
society
so when they hear a throwback guy like
me from back in the ancient days of
of geranimals
they often think this guy is just
whatever so if you think that i'm some
unhappy guy you're wrong having lived
the life i've lived and
seeing the other side not being afraid
to attack
what was in front of me has made me
happy say that again
in fact let me make sure i understood it
getting to the point where you're not
afraid to face the thing on the other
side of the door that wants to attack
you has made you happy right
right it's really powerful i hope people
heard that right that made me very happy
so
basically i just don't walk around with
a dad gonna smile my face all day in
time so you know merry christmas
but um but basically what the dark side
is
is
we all have
a cookie jar
and we all have a jar of
that's its official name it's a jar of
[ __ ] man we're
just
it just ain't going right
and in hell week what they do in hell
week because this is where i really went
to the dark side
what they're doing hell week is they
design hell week
to find your flaws
and they do a really good job of that
it's 130 hours of continuous training
you may get two hours of sleep and they
beat this out of you and find everything
wrong with your mentality
and then
they start hell week
and that's the beauty of it
and
for me
i'm not some not you know nasty
god-given guy you know i don't have a
great bit of talent in anything
so what got me through horrible times
was the dark side
was i created my name is david goggins
i created goggins
goggins is the guy
that can take anything you put in front
of them you want to break my
legs
so be it
i have a way of going to a place like i
did in that race
where all the pain and suffering that
they put on top of me in hell week
i will reverse that pain and suffering
and i will take your soul
so every instructor that put me through
buzz my job what drove me
was i wanted you to go home that night
after you beat the living out of me
and i smiled in your face
i wanted you to feel worse than i did
and you were going home to a nice warm
bed
with your wife or your kids in a nice
meal and i was still out there in the
grip
suffering for another 100 hours
i wanted you to think about me
knowing that i'm comfortable being very
uncomfortable and i want you to think
about when you went through a week how
uncomfortable you were and how bad you
wanted to quit
knowing i'm not thinking that
so the dark side is something that i've
designed
it's the evil place i can go
that
very few things
can hurt me
i use the hurt you're trying to put on
me
i flip it upside down and use it you try
to use it for kryptonite
no
it's power pillars for me
i'm using it for strength i just flipped
negative into positive it's all this my
family could even swim yeah you know
what i'm saying i mean my we had little
athletes in my family and um and i was a
kid who kind of got the kind of like the
the bad genes you know all these little
sickly issues all these allergic i was a
little sickly kid
and it's funny how when people hear my
story now they want to put a title on me
like um
i'm super human yeah like you had some
special
capability and i love it because
basically it makes you feel better by
putting a title on me right you can do
it too
that's right right and so
basically choice yeah it's a choice yeah
it's a horrible choice right it's a hard
choice it's a lot of suffering involved
so for me to get the start line
through that start line journey
i realized
i'm capable
so what happens to this whole process is
the change of the mind
it's a change of the guard
someone once owned my brain
i never owned it yeah i never had no i
had no control you out you outsourced it
yes right everybody had it it was my
dad's fault it was the kids that called
me [ __ ] fault my mom wasn't home fault
my soon-to-be stepdad's fault the little
kid that got rid of by the bus fault my
life was everybody had a piece of my
brain
and through this journey of suffering
and the suffering i put it in because i
started finding myself yeah i started oh
no i'm taking this [ __ ] back from me
this part of my brain is mine now i
start puzzling back this piece of my
brain and through that i grew confidence
so in this process i went from david
goggins i started forming a guy named
goggins
i had to really invent i realized i had
to reinvent a whole nother human being
right within myself because
who i am wasn't going to make it this is
not this guy is not going to cut it
so he i ought to be a guy who can take
any kind of pain
any kind of suffering any kind of
torture mentally physically emotionally
spiritually
i had to have the people who i
visualized everybody that called me
[ __ ] you had to be in a room of people
like this
i had to make up these things in my mind
of things i had to overcome
and i started callousing my mind
do it through a process it may start
with working out
it started with working out i started
with doing
like if it started raining outside for
instance
my mind would say man i'm gonna go run
if it was three o'clock in the morning
start raining outside my mind said
you gotta go get up and go around you
have to because i was fighting this
other person so you essentially
tried to do everything you didn't want
to do that's all it was period
everything i didn't want to do is what
got me to where i'm at today interesting
every single thing so
where we find comfort yeah that's where
i started getting scared yeah when i
started saying oh it's raining i'm not
going out there no you cannot say that
you cannot do that
you you have got to do this
the other so whatever my brain thought i
did the opposite
where the comfort wasn't with the
opposite direction and over a period of
time boy it callouses
out of your mind you start to really
develop a whole another being um growing
up being the kid i was i found strength
in different movies yeah so i come home
in one movie i found a lot of strength
as funny as it may seem but i visualize
this scene i do it today during the
pull-up record i did 4030 pull-ups
the last time i did it actually got it
took me three times i played one song
for 17 hours pretty much
it is from this movie
rocky one
round 14.
i related to the person in the movie
but just the one scene
when apollo's beating the rocky
he falls in the corner
and everybody and rocky and paul turns
around arms up happy i just i got this
guy
he turns around not knowing that rocky's
trying to get up off the canvas
mickey's saying mickey's his trainer
saying stay down everybody's saying you
did good
you did good you had 14 rounds with with
the champ
rocky didn't hear
he got up and was fixing my mind today
still and i'm seeing it right now when
he got up
apollo starts to turn around
to see the aftermath of what he just
destroyed
and he did not expect to see what he saw
right and what i see are the whole movie
i see apollo crease face yeah fear crept
in yes
and i said to myself as a young kid
i want to be that
i don't need to win
i don't need trophies i don't need
people to like me i just want what he
has yeah
a fictional character whatever the hell
it was i want that
and i visualized that
and i want to become the guy who can get
off the canvas and look at somebody who
beat the f out of him life
yeah it's about life right now
in life
even life itself pushed her head down
towards david god
not going to stop right so that
mentality
became
what i wanted nice
and that's how it started with that
visualization
of the canvas
and all i got to do is just keep getting
up this different mindset i turn
negatives into positives
so i would i would take like who who
would even think about doing this so i
would sit in my couch saying who at 297
who can't swim that great who's scared
of the water would have the balls
clear the balls to man up quit a job and
go and put everything on himself
so it's how i start talking to myself
and put myself in a whole different
category and that would fuel me the next
day and i just kept using that as fuel
and fuel no one would do this
no one would do it
around
never live
and i had kept fueling me with the with
the right kind of message that i needed
to hear that i was never telling myself
and through time
it became reality
to myself
so
you start out on the first day and then
do you start running again the second
day yeah the second day we're right back
after it again but i started realizing i
can't run that far right so what i did
was i became
near a professional cyclist with the
miles i put on the bike
so i never
whenever i watched tv
i had to be doing something so i was
riding the bike i rode a bike a lot to
to lose the first initial kind of weight
because my bones were just hurting so
bad my body was broken and i learned to
get over that also and i tried to swim a
lot i want a great swimmer but putting
fins on kind of equalized my body i
wasn't so negative buoyant so i started
fitting a whole bunch and i spent hours
in the pool hours in the pool trying to
get more and more comfortable not
because i was going underwater i was so
scared of the water that i had to live
in the water
i had to become one with the water so
going to the pool used to scare me
so i went to the pool an awful awful lot
and then the bike got easier i was able
to run more i went from like one mile
one mile was a great accomplishment two
miles and then from two to three was a
big one then i went from three to six
and then
like they have a warning order that they
give people to get ready for buds and
the whole thing was running six miles
five days a week
and that was my goal
and so i just kept i failed i go back to
scratch
i use some positive motivation i have
like one day when i'm like defeated
but i started realizing this is part of
the process this is part of the journey
i had to realize this is part of my
process versus just saying like i used
to i'm just not good enough
if i'm not good enough we always say
that i'm just not good enough maybe try
something else i'm gonna make myself
good enough
and that became my mentality
i'm gonna make myself good enough
and so i misunderstood a lot
but that's that's all it came down to i
made myself good enough and the days i
couldn't run that far the next week
i would do two a days
so like on the running if i ran a
quarter a mile i wait a few hours it'd
haunt me bother me i try to win a half a
mile next time same day
you can do more than this if i had to
walk i had to walk it just became just a
process of grinding and grinding and
grinding is not even a good word for it
it's not even a good word for it
and just just going further and further
and then when i got through running i go
to the bike i go to the pool if i got
tired somewhere my legs retired i go to
the gym and i develop this crazy workout
where i was doing volume like
two three hundred reps of like very
light weight people say how you know how
come you have any like loose skin
my workout routine in the gym became
sick it became sick i was just doing two
300 reps 400 reps on like chest just
like for one simple exercise the bench
press
and i rack it get back on it just rep it
out trying to burn as many calories i
can build that muscle mass you once said
that if you were growing up in this
generation that you would have a field
day because you would take their souls
what did you mean by that the the
younger generation quits
not everybody
so i gotta i gotta put that people get
their butt hurt so not everybody
most of this generation quits the second
they get
talked to
you did this wrong you did this wrong or
or they get yelled at it's so easy to
you know to be great nowadays because
everybody else is most people are weak
this this is a softened generation so if
you have any mental toughness
any any ability if you have any fraction
of self-discipline
the ability to
not want to do it but still do it people
have a hard thing to understand i hate
to run and and what makes me so crazy
it doesn't need more is people well why
do you run if you hate it what are you
talking about i don't want to take
showers and eat either i hate that too
the whole that's a life man
that and and it it wasn't until i
changed that mentality that i became
somebody
i hated going to school so guess what i
was
that's what
one plus one is two
but if you can get through
to doing things that you hate to do
on the other side is greatness
that's what people understand by me
running i am callous in my mind i'm not
training for a race
i'm training for life
i'm training for the time when i get
that two o'clock in the morning call
that my mom is dead or something happens
tragic in life
i don't fall apart
i'm training my mind and my body my
spirit so it's all one so i can handle
what life is gonna throw at me because
the life i've lived
it throws a whole bunch at you
and if you're not physically immensely
prepared for that
you're just going to crumble and you're
good for nobody
talk to me about what it takes to be on
one side of a door in iraq or anywhere
knowing on the other side of the door
people who are not afraid of you
they're ready for you to come in and you
still have and they have guns and you
still have to breach that door
that's that's a great question it
that's
a very scary situation when you are
on one side of the door
and your mind is racing because on the
other side of that door
it could be no one
it could be four guys with four ak-47s
that
that door you're about to open could be
booby-trapped so once you open it boom
your legs are gone
so
there's a thousand things you think
about when you're the first guy second
guy third guy getting ready to go in a
room and flood it and that's why i talk
about the warrior mentality and that's
why so many people
are lost when i start talking
you have
the right
you're lucky
that you don't have to think like
warriors think you're very privileged i
chose this world to be a warrior now and
i would choose it again if i came back
to this world
but the mentality of a warrior is very
different than normal mentality
you must be that person on that door oh
get ready to open it thinking to
yourself
if i die
so be it
the only way you can go in that door is
knowing there's a great chance you're
going to die like being a seal you train
with live ammo you jump on an airplane
every everything you do
you could die
so to be a warrior why people don't
understand me i'm glad you don't
understand me merry christmas good on
you because being a warrior takes a
whole different mindset
a whole different mindset to know that
there's a great chance i may not be in
the like i was in for 21 years i'm lucky
i'm very lucky that i'm alive able to
talk to you able to still run
but when you sign up on that dialogue to
be a like a seal your mentality changes
i may not live
you gotta accept that
and that's the mentality you have and
that's what makes you a warrior if
you're scared to die
you're a bad warrior i hated jumping out
of airplanes
i hated shooting guns
i hated the job as a navy seal
but i did it because i wanted to
change myself
everything i do i'm not really
comfortable doing
but if you choose to go that route to go
be a navy seal
you might as well go be the hardest in
the world
because if you're choosing to do
something you have two routes you can go
there and be a little a little weak
person
and get through barely and that's your
reputation
or you can go through
the hardest guy you can possibly be
that's your reputation so my whole thing
is if you're going to choose to open
that door in iraq or afghanistan open
them and go in hard
because they're going to remember you
by slowly opening it and peeking in
so if you're going to open it and you
made the mind open it don't crack it
open open the door go in that's with
life
if you're choosing to do if you're
choosing to do something attack it
because they're going to remember you
as not attacking it so i want to be
remembered you can hate me but one thing
you can't say about me i didn't attack
it
so that's the mentality you have if
you're going to do something you might
as well attack it because you could do
it anyway right
do you use that in civilian life like do
you still
employ the i'm going to attack it i'm
going to take their souls like how does
that play out in a non-um
combat
zone it still works for me in in life as
far as attacking things
because uh no matter what i want to you
know no matter what avenue i choose i
want to be the very best
and the very best may not be
i'm number one
the very best is did i leave everything
inside of me
out there
so attacking is not like oh i want to
win this or win that or be the best
the best is i'm i'm running against
myself and everything i do
and and that's and that's what i attack
i attack myself
i'm always questioning myself as a
leader the one thing i did horribly
wrong on my second platoon i actually um
started developing an attitude towards
people who didn't pee too hard
who didn't get after who worked because
i know
i i took it all the way to the limit and
so i should have been a better leader by
no one okay now everybody wants to be
david goggins yeah everybody wants to go
run a hundred miles everybody everyone's
got different everybody's got different
skill sets and you know right you know
maybe you know want to go to the gym
whatever the gym is fine but it was just
a different standard so i couldn't take
away my standard for the whole of the
group interesting i looked at people
man you know yeah you ain't trying to
get
so my mentality i wasn't a good leader
and i look back on that now
trust me a lot of people could do things
differently i'm taking accountability
for what i could have done differently
i looked at that so my mentality from a
weak kid became super hard
like beyond hard next level hard and um
but that's what i was getting myself
into as a leader i should have stepped
back and was hey these are your
expectations david goggins right
what are we here to accomplish right
it's important to lead by example and
when i say lead by example
if you're the leader it's the longest
job on the planet
and if you do it
you have to be up early you have to
leave late you got to do the sucky jobs
at least that's how i look at it you got
to be the man that is is is always the
person
who's being held accountable to the
highest standard
and not expecting your people to do
anything that you're not going to do 20
times more than they are even when even
when you're the leader
and and i and it's it's all about
accountability for yourself in
leadership roles not about being pissed
because
people aren't doing what you're doing
[Applause]
when you think that you are done you're
only 40
into what your body's capable of doing
and that's just the limits that that we
put on ourselves
[Music]
got our leader of the 150 mile coming in
mr david
you never really know how i feel i never
really tell you the truth i'm always
going to feel good he's a person
i want to feel and show you no weakness
congratulations thanks a lot man 150
mile champion first place new course
record way to go congratulations
i'm never happy and satisfied with
one thing i do it's always a continuous
journey and in all my races they
they never end they just kind of fall in
together so when things hit you in life
that you're afraid of or you're not good
at
the first thing you're going to say to
yourself is
why am i here anyway
this isn't for me
the water's too cold
the sun's too hot
i'm getting up too early why am i doing
this to myself
that's what the normal mind says
i had to start training my mind to think
about
how the
can i get through this
not giving myself a way out
never giving myself creating a wall
around all the ways out in my mind i
just slowly started to build this wall
so my mind knew
this
is not going to give himself a way out
of here in my first tail week i had a
huge setback
i was broken
my legs were broken i had double
pneumonia
i got rolled back to day one week one of
navy seal training
i got through that second hell week
during the second hell week i actually
broke my knee i continued to limp around
for a couple weeks
i couldn't make it anymore got rolled
back to day one week one
i never forget standing there in front
of captain bowen he was the ceo in
charge of navy seal train at the time
and he had no mercy on anybody
if he believed in
managing your expectations
i wouldn't be here today he challenged
me again
i was challenged my whole life not by
the mindset of managing expectations by
exceeding expectations not by managing
them i'm standing there
with crutches
i'm sitting in his office he looks at me
he goes dog is this your last time
we're gonna put you through navy seal
training
this will be your third hell week in one
year
we're not gonna put you through a fourth
so this is your last time
i'm sitting thinking how am i gonna get
through this
i'm i'm badly jacked up my legs are
broken my knee is messed up
and he goes you have a couple of months
to get better
a couple months isn't going to do it
i won't get healed up in a couple of
months
but i realized i'm going to get through
this
i'm going to find a way to get through
it because why i put barriers in my mind
so my third hell week i went in there
with pretty much i would put a black
sock
on first
i would get duct tape
and i duct tape my ankles all the way up
to my calf every single morning and then
i put another black sock over it
and what that did that prevented me
from moving
my ankle
so i didn't really
i wasn't flexing my shin as much
and i started running with just my hip
flexors
in this hell week it was a bad hell we
had a guy die on thursday morning of
hell week
i went on to become a navy seal
greatness is not something that you meet
once
it's something that you meet
thousands of times in your life and you
don't reach it
if you're not constantly in constant
pursuit of
greatness
so if my mind were to say right now i'm
great
i just lost
we're going to grow
we're not going to triple down on our
strengths
we're not going to do that crap
we're going to work on our weaknesses so
we grow we need friction to do that
without friction there's no growth
without friction there's confusion
confusion is david goggins how did you
become who you are today
i put a bunch of friction in my life
and i grew
that's how i did it you know you get
really tough
it's a lifestyle
instead of hitting that news button in
the morning and not making your bed not
cleaning your house
you don't hit this news button you get
up you don't want to go run you go run
you don't want to go swimming you go
swim you want to make your beds you make
your bed you don't want to clean your
house and clean your house you don't
want to study
study that's how you start to callous
your mind so that became my life
if you say you're gonna wake up at four
o'clock in the morning to go run
wake up at four o'clock and it's gonna
suck
it's not gonna be fun
do something that sucks every single day
of your life that's how you grow
embrace the suck if you want more
inspiration morning videos they're not
on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it it's right
there next to me go click it there
continue to believe and i'll see you
there